ce sommet virtuel chimie européenne
réunis charles michel président du
conseil européen
our souls à van der leyen président de
la commission européenne la chancelière
allemande angela merkel et le président
chinois xi jingping objectif principal
faire avancer le projet d'accord sino
européen sur le traité bilatéral
d'investissement
négocié depuis près de sept ans il vise
la protection des investissements
bilatéraux entre l'union européenne et
la chine
un vaste projet qui aborde la propriété
intellectuelle la fin des transferts de
technologie imposer aux firmes
étrangères en chine et les subventions
aux entreprises publiques chinoises
selon la commission européenne
sur les dix dernières années la chine
aura investi plus de 145 milliards
d'euros sur le vieux continent
problème aujourd'hui les négociations
semblent difficiles alors que les
tensions entre les deux parties ne
cessent de se multiplier
hong kong mer de chine question des
ouigours 5 g ou encore taïwan
malgré les divergences pékin réaffirme
sa volonté de conclure l'accord ce n'est
pas la vérité à propos du fait que la
chine bloque les progrès du traité
bilatéral d'investissement
il est précisé que nous faisons avancer
les négociations du traité
même pendant l'épidémie nous essayons
d'accélérer cette négociation avec
l'europe
je peux vous dire que cette négociation
a atteint le stade final que le problème
le plus difficile a été résolu et qu'une
solution a été trouvée chez eux mais
échaudés par la guerre commerciale et
les invectives entre chine et états unis
les européens jouent l'apaisement mais
l'union européenne n est pas prête à
tous les sacrifices pour à l'accord on
espère s'entendre lundi sur une feuille
de route pour aplanir nos différents
mais même si l'objectif politique et
d'accélérer les négociations et de
conclure d'ici fin 2020 on acceptera un
accord seulement s'il vaut le coup et si
de gros avancées ne sont pas à prévoir
lors de ce sommet le contexte de relance
économique sur fond de crise sanitaire
devrait néanmoins permettre aux deux
parties de trouver un terrain d'entente